[MUSIC PLAYING]
JELENA MIJUSKOVIC: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jelena, a customer
engineer at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to the technical
series for startups,
where we're creating a series of
videos for technical enablement
to help startups to
start, build, and grow
their businesses
successfully and sustainably
in Google Cloud.
In the previous video, we
covered storage and database
portfolio in Google Cloud.
And in this episode
we're going to talk
about Firebase, our application
development platform.
In this video, we're going to
cover introduction to Firebase,
what common development
problem it solves,
and what product it includes.
After that, we're
going to look into what
set of services
application developers
can use to build
better applications,
improve their
application quality,
and engage their users.
We'll go over a
customer success story,
then we will run through
the Firebase console
and how to connect an
Android app to Firebase.
And finally, we will wrap
up with some resources
you can follow up with.
So what is Firebase?
Firebase is our mobile
development platform
that allows you to quickly
build and grow your app.
Using Firebase, we provide a
set of tools and Cloud Services
that help mobile and
web developers solve
common challenges across
the app lifecycle--
from building an app, to
improving its quality,
to increasing user engagement.
Firebase is easy to integrate
on iOS, Android, and the web,
as well as C++ and Unity to
support for game developers.
We have a purpose-built SDK
for each popular platform
to help you move
quickly and help
ensure that your app is the
same quality on every platform.
After this short
introduction to Firebase,
let's take a look at a
typical application lifecycle,
which has three main phases.
The first phase is
the development phase,
when you're developing
a brand new app
or adding a new functionality
to an existing app.
Once your application
is ready, you
want to share it
with your users,
but in a controlled
fashion, while keeping
an eye on any potential
crashes that may happen.
Finally, once your users
start enjoying the new app,
you want to learn
more about them--
identify the most
valuable users and decide
to further personalize their
experience to retain them.
Firebase, with its
comprehensive set
of tools and Cloud
Services, helps
solve these three core problems
in your application lifecycle.
There are 19 services that are
divided into three categories--
build better application,
improve application quality,
drive user engagement.
Starting from the
left, if you're
building a new
application, Firebase
offers a completely serverless
approach to getting started.
Once the application
is built, we
offer tools to
help you to improve
stability and performance
of your application.
Then finally, we
have a set of tools
to help you drive user
engagement and retention.
Let's start with the development
phase category of products.
Let's take a look at your normal
app architecture, something
that most of you
probably recognize
from your own projects.
You've got your
mobile app, which
communicates with your main
frontend server using a REST
API.
That server talks to your
all other backend services.
You've probably got a
server for authentication
and a server for media files.
You also have a database, which
is one of the first decisions
that app developers make.
You may be concerned
about your infrastructure
and how it will grow
with your company.
What about if you want
to include new platforms?
How would you scale
your frontend server?
Is your authentication
server secure?
Is your media server
terabytes ready,
and database fast enough?
Instead of the
diagram before, here
is what it looks
like with Firebase.
Let's build together
a mobile app that
process user-generated content.
It could be a photo
album, accessible
from both mobile
and web interfaces,
that attacks and extracts from
any image uploaded by the user
and presents the result
back to the user.
The first step in designing
our app architecture
is user authentication.
Firebase authentication is
an out-of-box authentication
UI that supports email and
password phone authentication,
and Facebook and many others.
Now that the user
is authenticated,
they can upload their image to
Cloud storage, a secure place
in the Cloud for user content.
The event of a new image
uploaded to Cloud Storage
will trigger Cloud
Functions that, in our case,
will perform optical character
recognition on the image.
Firebase ML Kit makes it
easy to access machine
learning models from your app.
Now that we have extracted
the text from the image,
we will store it in Cloud
Firestore, a real time NoSQL
database.
A Cloud app can subscribe to
notifications of new data being
stored in Cloud Firestore.
And so our users quickly
receive a notification
of what text has been
extracted from their image.
The user confirms that the
text is indeed correct.
If we were building a
Cloud-native app from scratch,
we may finish our work here.
But what if we're adding
a Cloud-native module
to an existing legacy app that's
running most of its legacy
logic on-prem?
In that case, you can
simply expose the Secure API
to your legacy backend and
utilize Cloud Functions
to notify the backend
every time user approved
a new entry to Cloud Firestore.
Now that we covered the
benefits of developing
apps with Firebase, let's talk
about keeping them healthy.
Firebase can help here too.
So you have built your app.
It's got a huge list
of great features.
It's doing well in
your alpha test.
You're sure it's better
than anything out there.
But what if your application
is buggy or unstable
in the real world?
You may receive bad reviews.
If your application crashes,
user may become unhappy
and might leave
negative reviews that
scare away potential new users.
What can you do?
Let's see how Firebase
can help you too.
You have just finished
developing a new feature
for your application and you're
ready to publish the updated
application to Apple
and Play Stores.
When rolling out
a new feature, you
may want to push it to a small
percentage of users first.
With Firebase, you are in
full control of your rollout.
First, before you upload a
new build to the app stores,
you can put a new feature
behind the feature
flag using Remote Config.
Then, using Google
Analytics for Firebase,
you can select
the one percentage
of users who will experience
the new feature first.
Once the one percentage of users
have the new feature enabled,
you can use Firebase Performance
Monitoring and crash analytics
to monitor user experience
who have new feature enabled
and look for any
potential app crashes
that new feature may cause.
We can dive more
deeply into our data
by exporting it to BigQuery.
Soon, we'll have identified
that the app only crashes
for the users with
very old devices,
but works fine on almost
100% of the devices.
At this point, you may want to
exclude the problematic devices
from your rollout while allowing
the vast majority of your users
to enjoy the new feature.
Finally, we have arrived at
the perhaps most critical stage
of the application lifecycle.
Once the application built with
Firebase is out in the world
and you know it performs as
expected with all Firebase
monitoring dashboards
indicating health,
you can focus on
acquiring and retaining
your most valuable users.
First and foremost, you
need to know your users.
With Google Analytics, you
can easily divide your users
into audience segments
so you can further
personalize their experience.
Next, with Predictions,
you can utilize
machine learning to predict
future user behavior based
on the historical events
captured in Analytics.
Finally, if you really need
to dive deeply into your data,
you can mirror all the
events to BigQuery.
After you understand and start
segmenting your user base,
it's time to start experimenting
optimizing your application
performance.
Core to this is
Remote Config, that
allows you to remotely change
your application behavior
without the need to
ship a new build,
which would be time consuming
and inconvenient for the user.
Combined with Google
Analytics and A/B testing,
you can design and
execute experiments
to test what makes the
most optimal app experience
for a targeted segment.
Finally, you need tools to
help retain your existing users
and acquire new ones.
In-app messaging offers
push notifications
that pop up in
the app to present
your most valuable users with
a special offer, for example.
Cloud Messaging
will help you reach
your users who haven't
visited your app in a few days
to reengage them.
Finally, if you're planning
a marketing campaign
and you want to
advertise your app
on, say, third-party
websites, Dynamic Links
will be a great tool.
Dynamic Links will help
your prospects look
at your app in the
respective app stores.
If the user clicks on the
link from an Android device,
they will automatically
land in the Play Store,
while an iOS user will be
pointed to the Apple store.
Many customers use Firebase
to build and operate
their applications.
One of them is
Surfboard Payments,
a Swedish-based
fintech developing
next-generation
payment solutions.
By downloading
their application,
any merchant can start accepting
electronic payments in minutes.
Surfboard Payments
used Firebase in order
to be able to prototype
quickly, spot errors
by testing before
releasing, and sync
in-store user-generated
content in real time.
Now, let's go over a
short demonstration
of how to connect an
Android app to Firebase.
Step one, create a
Firebase project.
In the Firebase console,
click add project.
To create a new project, enter
the desired project name.
If prompted, review and
accept the Firebase terms.
Click Continue.
Optional step is to
set up Google Analytics
for your project or use
an existing account.
And I'm going to use my
Analytics account, which I
already created for this demo.
Click Create Project.
Firebase automatically
provisions resources
for your Firebase project.
When the process
is complete, you'll
be taken to the Overview page
for your Firebase project
in the Firebase console.
Step two, register your
application with Firebase.
Go to the Firebase console.
In the center of the
Project Overview page,
click the Android
icon or Add App
to launch the setup workflow.
Enter your app's package name in
the Android package name field.
Click Register App.
Step three, add Firebase
configuration file.
To add the Firebase
Android configuration file,
first click Download
google-services.json file
to obtain your Firebase
Android configuration file.
In the second step, move
your configuration file
into the module app-level
directory of your app.
In the project-level
Gradle file,
add rules to include Google
services Gradle plugin.
Make sure that you have Google's
Maven repository as well.
In the app-level Gradle file,
apply the Google services
Gradle plugin.
Step four, add Firebase SDK.
Using the Firebase Android
BoM, declare the dependencies
for your Firebase products that
you want to use in your app.
Declare them in your
app-level Gradle file.
Sync your app in order to ensure
that all dependencies have
the necessary versions.
And that's it.
You managed to successfully
add your app to Firebase.
And this brings us to the
end of this video, where
we learned that Firebase
has an array of offerings
that help developers to
work better and faster.
To continue to
explore what Firebase
has to offer in further details,
check out our suggestions
here--
and don't forget on the
links in the description.
We will see you
next time, when we
will go over different
services and tools for CI/CD
on Google Cloud.
Don't forget to
like and subscribe
to our YouTube channel.
Click on the bell icon
to get notified each time
a new video is posted.
Thank you and see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]